a one-room apartment in Northeast Mumbai
chaya gai quarte lives here with her
large family Chaya dropped out of school
when she was 10 she cooked and fleet
informally in different Mumbai homes for
decades the work was back working the
jobs irregular and the plane I had hard
time my previous employers used to yell
at me they would threaten to fire me if
I didn't show up on time if I didn't do
the tasks fast enough I was constantly
worried that changed a year ago when
Chaya joined my didi calm a mobile
application that connects cleaning staff
with households in Mumbai Chaya now
enters new recruits in housekeeping the
maids receive a fixed salary that gets
paid into the bank accounts conditions
that are unheard of among India's
domestic servants it's an industry
that's highly informal and unorganized
Chaya takes home nearly twelve thousand
rupees or 162 euros a month nearly sixty
percent more than a previous income
employees also given a smartphone and
trained in using the app founder Johnny
cha grew up with household hell like
most urban Indians with many maids they
hired being illiterate or semi-literate
he says his developers struggled to make
the app user-friendly all of them
Bollywood was the answer
unicef shahrukh to start the order jar
says the aim is to make the sector more
efficient by improving the skills of
domestic workers and it's not just the
but also the employers who have to
change the trier heads off to a new
assignment
she works in about four to five homes
every day for an hour each the company
organizes transport to ferry maids to
their workplace today Chaya is a clean
up job on the 17th floor of luxury
building 3 the oak turn to my didi after
her regular maid abruptly stopped coming
leaving her in the lurch
she initially had reservations about
quality and service and whether she
could trust a complete stranger in a
home but not anymore no hassles and then
nothing and they would replace supposing
one maid is sick or anything they would
send another maid so no hassle actually
was quite relaxing I would say I would
just tell her what to do and then you
would do a work for Chaya
joining the my didi platform has
certainly paid off but the biggest
change she says is how she is now
treated in a society notorious for
condescending attitudes towards
household help wala galya galya the way
I make my customers actually greet me
first and say namaste didi how are you
I'm overwhelmed I'm not used to it
they tell me you're a human being too
they treat me like a family member
thanks to technology
India's invisible domestic workforce is
embracing modernity and living a more
dignified life